bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors on
agite la menace d'un retour au pouvoir
des talibans alors qu'on vient de leur
faire vingt ans de guerre ça veut dire
quoi que la présence américaine sur le
sol afghan
finalement on n'a rien donné non peut
pas tout à fait dire ça mais c'est sûr
que c'est une fin de partie en
afghanistan
l'échéancier est programmé il est mis en
oeuvre d'ailleurs et anthony blinken le
secrétaire d'état de joe biden a dit
façon que rester n'était pas une option
donc c'est ça justifie le départ
effectivement qui est déjà très engagé
puisqu'on parle de 50% déjà de de
retrait il reste la base la grande base
de bagram mais c'est incontestablement
une fragilisation du gouvernement afghan
qu'il perçoit doudou le doubs le périple
effectivement washington ou de la façade
est respectée la façade est sauvé mais
évidemment les inquiétudes pointent
parce que il ya une pression militaire
accrue sur le terrain des talibans et
notamment autour des vides alors à ce
rappeur annie donc venu chercher un
soutien financier auprès de drogba eden
c'est ça qu'elle obtiendra s'est passé
un an c'est un soutien global en réalité
qui recherchait on parle de partenariat
effectivement les américains veulent
montrer qui a pas un abandon de
l'afghanistan c'est un peu le syndrome
vietnamien qui joue à plein on va dire
et donc l'idée c'est effectivement de
maintenir de toute façon une forme de
partenariat avec de gros doutes sur la
capacité du gouvernement afghan à
résister une fois le une fois le le
retrait militaire américain achevé
d'ailleurs ça avait pointé dans
certaines déclarations des chefs
militaires américains notamment canettes
mackenzie qu'est le chef du centcom
commandement central à qui couvre l'asie
centrale qui avait dit ce qui vient
inquiéter c'est la capacité des forces
afghanes à résister sans le soutien
notamment aériens justement américain
aux offensive talibane ce qui avait
permis aux forces afghanes de reprendre
et vite quand elle était tombée
notamment koundouz qui fait l'objet
aujourd'hui d'une pression
particulièrement forte
justement dans le nord de l'afghanistan
il porte parole john kirby du pentagone
disait qu effectivement lorsque le
soutien
s'achèvera la question sera sera posée
les le support militaire directe
américain sera plus disponible et ce
sera le moment de vérité évidemment pour
les forces afghanes dont certaines sont
sujettes à caution en termes de
militaires dont concrètement ça veut
dire qu'une fois que les troupes
américaines seront repartis les forces
afghanes seront seuls face aux talibans
à quel point l'armée afghane est elle
équipée en termes de matériel et
humainement même il faut rappeler quand
même qu'il ya eu près de 90 milliards de
dollars pour la formation des forces
afghanes qui ont été allouées justement
parlé par les américains dans ce qui
n'est pas rien il ya une partie de ses
forces qui sont opérationnels mais il ya
un noyau dur on va dire de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers mais sur l'ensemble
des trois cent mille affiches évidemment
on en est loin et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui pousse aujourd'hui le président
ashraf ghani à aller c'est une logique
milicienne se mettre en place comme
substituts comme palliatif justement aux
éventuels déficience médite faute forces
afghanes et on retrouve assez
étrangement lier un mécanisme qui
s'était produit au moment d'aller du nez
par de l'armée soviétique en 1904 88 89
avec justement le recours à ces milices
avec le risque qui plane d'une guerre
civile de retour de la guerre civile
puisque il ya un tropisme ethno
confessionnelles qui de toute façon et
est afghan et donc on va retrouver des
logis que tadjikes et hazara pachtoune
sursis au fond évidemment d'affrontement
avec avec les talibans et au niveau des
pourparlers où ça en est on sait que
sera fera ni à proposer aux talibans de
faire partie du gouvernement intérimaire
manifestement ça n'a pas l'air de les
intéresser
oui il faut d'ailleurs rappeler que
c'était demande expresse d'anthony
américaine puisqu'il avait fait un
courrier le 4 le 4 mars dernier où il
enjoignait le gouvernement justement
d'achraf rami à se montrer plus disposée
justement vis-à-vis des talibans alors
en d'ailleurs en menaçant animaux en lui
disant que même avec la poursuite d'une
aide financière américaine le la
situation sécuritaire
de toute façon risqué de se dégrader
s'il n'y avait pas un effort avérée de
la part des gouvernements de discuter le
problème c'est qu'en face les talibans
joue la montre et sont dans une
situation qu'il considère être une
situation qui devrait très favorable et
donc ils traînent des pieds évidemment
pour pour rentrer dans cette logique de
négociation même si à terme elle
pourrait leur être favorable et de toute
façon ils pensent que quelle que soit la
configuration
la situation et leur est favorable ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils sont
proches de prendre le pouvoir à kaboul
on n'en est pas là parce que jusqu'à
présent les villes aucune des grandes
villes
même s'il ya effectivement une
soixantaine de district sur 370 qui
serait passé sous leur contrôle direct
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de grandes
capitales on va dire provincial qui est
tombée et la vraie question ça va être
ça parce qu'effectivement la question de
l'infiltration des villes et notamment
la question de kaboul qui évidemment le
le point central savoir si kaboul est en
mesure de résister justement une
pression militaire d'êta des talibans
qui sont dans toutes les périphéries de
ségovie david rigoulet roze merci avant
je rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de leurs vues aux rayons
stratégiques et spécialiste du
moyen-orient merci